[Música]
a
escala en parís braulio more
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español donde damos la palabra a
artistas políticos personajes del mundo
de las ciencias de las artes y de la
sociedad civil un grupo de
investigadores políticos y dirigentes de
organizaciones internacionales han unido
sus esfuerzos para reflexionar acerca de
los desafíos obstáculos y alternativas
que se presentan a américa latina y el
caribe tras la pandemia de la cob y 19
la publicación de la nueva revista de
política cultura y arte con el título
américa latina' mirar al futuro recoge
estas reflexiones coordinadores de ese
trabajo es gaspar estrada politólogo
director ejecutivo del observatorio
político para américa latina y el caribe
el opal del instituto de ciencias
políticas de parís gaspar bienvenido una
vez más a esta escala en parís ola a
braille un saludo a ti ya tu auditorio
muchísimas gracias un gusto tenerle con
nosotros cuál es el objetivo de la nueva
revista de política que ustedes acaban
de publicar
la idea es bastante simple américa
latina siempre ha sido una región que ha
suscitado el interés del ex presidente
del gobierno de españa felipe gonzález
durante sus gobiernos
españa y américa latina habían tenido
pues una relación bastante fructífera él
sigue teniendo un interés por la región
y yo conozco al expresidente desde hace
algunos años y él me invitó junto con su
fundación a coordinar este trabajo
teniendo en cuenta que su fundación
tiene un acuerdo de colaboración con
esta revista y fue en el contexto de
este interés común en los desafíos de
américa latina tras la pandemia que
surgió la idea de hacer una publicación
que en el fondo haga un balance de la
situación actual de la región y que
también atrás se escenarios a futuro
esta revista américa latina' mirando al
futuro vamos a decir se divide en cuatro
grandes capítulos vamos a ir las cuatro
patas de una región donde las
alternativas son inestabilidad
regresión económica generalmente tenemos
también el problema de la insatisfacción
de la población y sobre todo la búsqueda
de nuevas alternativas así es yo creo
que el problema central que
presenta está esta publicación pues
muestra una ha sido una situación
latinoamericana complicada después de la
pandemia con
en el escenario de desafíos
institucionales fuertes que ese es el
primer la primera parte con democracias
fatigadas como lo dice manuel alcántara
uno de los autores de este de esta
publicación que también tiene desafíos
en sus relaciones entre poder civil el
poder militar pero también una nueva
generación de líderes no que es lo que
yo explico en el primer en el primer
capítulo que traen una nueva agenda que
es fruto también de mobile movimientos
sociales de movilizaciones populares y
que contribuye a poner a américa latina
digamos adelante en algunos en algunos
debates pienso por ejemplo en el tema de
la despenalización del aborto que ha
avanzado en américa latino cuando vemos
que por ejemplo en eeuu ese debate está
retrocediendo entonces yo creo que la
situación no es totalmente mala pero si
hay desafíos muy grandes en particular
en el tema de la desigualdad que es el
objeto de el segundo capítulo de este de
este libro con un estonces y de estudios
muy buenos me parece de
diego sánchez en coche de la universidad
de oxford también del plus que hacen un
balance un poco de la situación y que
hacen una serie de propuestas para ir
más allá a este propósito gaspar de las
12 contribuciones que integran la
revista hay una constante en ellas uno
se requiere un nuevo contrato social así
es dos se requiere que la
latinoamérica como tal continente busque
un nuevo modelo de desarrollo son dos
elementos que se han venido dijéramos
repitiendo desde hace años que es lo que
está faltando a esa región a esos países
para que finalmente el nuevo contrato y
el nuevo modelo puedan ponerse en marcha
bueno yo creo que lo que es necesario es
construir las mayorías políticas las
coaliciones que permitan avanzar en un
cierto número de temas que me parecen
que son imprescindibles yo creo que el
primero es la reforma fiscal cómo hacer
para que la región progresivamente vea
disminuir sus índices de desigualdad y
contribuir a que la economía funcione de
una mejor manera cuando la renta está
demasiado concentrada
eso inhibe la productividad del
desarrollo económico y eso justamente es
el objeto de uno de los artículos de
este libro y para ello pues hay que
construir mayorías políticas y el mundo
académico tiene que salir un poco de su
torre de marfil
y buscar la sociedad para justamente
alertar sobre estos temas y ese también
es uno de los objetivos de esta
publicación y una de las digamos de los
planteamientos que que me hizo el
presidente gonzález cuando surgió la
idea del libro para explorar la mayoría
de los países de américa latina ustedes
lo recuerdan viven en lo que podríamos
llamar un periodo de democracia de hace
bastantes décadas ya más de tres décadas
al mismo tiempo esta es una democracia
un tipo de democracia endeble frágil y
sobre todo que sigue generando mucha
insatisfacción sin duda y yo creo que
ese es uno de los principales desafíos
de la política y de los políticos en
américa latina como reconectar
y las élites con sus sociedades las
élites políticas pero también las élites
económicas es un buen ejemplo de ello es
lo que ha estado sucediendo en chile en
los últimos años un país que en los años
90 2000 era vendido como un modelo de
crecimiento incluyente no pero que lo
vimos inclusive antes de la pandemia con
una serie de protestas insatisfacción
muy fuerte de la sociedad y ahora con un
nuevo líder una convención constituyente
que está ahí pero que también enfrenta
muchos desafíos entonces yo creo que hay
que seguir eso con mucho cuidado con
mucha atención pero también con una
perspectiva positiva a futuro hacía
referencia al tema de la desigualdad que
efectivamente el artículo de diego
sánchez ancochea insiste mucho en este
terreno y avance de una cuestión que no
es nueva pero que vale la pena repetirlo
primero de los 20 países con mayor
desigualdad en el mundo 10 son
latinoamericanos brasil costa rica
notablemente méxico aparecen en esta
nefasta lista si se puede llamar así
pero al mismo tiempo el rey existe una
cosa no es un problema económico es un
problema de decisión política combatir
esta situación
así es y yo creo que diego también
insiste y con mucha razón en la
necesidad de construir estas coaliciones
políticas de estas mayorías para poder
transitar
hacia sociedades más justas y sobre todo
que las medidas que se tomen para
combatir la desigualdad tengan un
impacto en el tiempo una de las críticas
y una de las constataciones que hace
diego en su capítulo van justamente en
ese sentido decir en los años 2000 se se
pudo pensar que la región mejoraba sus
indicadores ya sean indicadores de
pobreza pero también indicadores de
desigualdad y luego que vimos en la
década siguiente es que pues estos estos
avances pues fueron muy rápidamente
reversibles no y se perdió mucho en los
últimos años y con la pandemia pues
todavía más entonces yo creo que es un
elemento que me parece es importante
destacar es que estas reformas tienen
que tener un impacto en el tiempo y eso
es un elemento muy importante para
corregir esta desigualdad
pues que es muy grande en américa la
quiero referirme a otro de los capítulos
que llamó bastante mi atención que es el
papel de las fuerzas armadas elaborado
por ruth díaz min
ella insiste una cosa que es bastante
interesante efectivamente tras las
dictaduras militares que se vivieron en
américa latina' los militares se
retiraron fueron hechos a un lado de la
política y en los últimos años hemos
visto una vuelta incluso casi casi que
triunfante entre comillas de esos
militares en brasil el presidente
bolsonaro ha nombrado varios ministros
militares pero sobre todo en chile en
bolivia en ecuador los gobiernos durarán
hasta el 2019 recurrieron varias veces a
los militares para calmar para aplastar
incluso olas de protestas que había en
esa región así es y no sólo eso sino que
ya sean gobiernos de extrema derecha
como los de bolsonaro pero también en
gobiernos de izquierda como el de lópez
obrador las prerrogativas que se le han
dado a los militares no han dejado de
aumentar en méxico hoy en día es el
ejército que construye bueno que
construyó el aeropuerto de la ciudad de
mexico que está a cargo de los puertos
que ésta creo buena parte de las obras
públicas y por ende se plantean
y de la no pertinencia más bien de este
aumento de las prerrogativas de los
militares en actividades civiles lo que
más me parece es es importante destacar
en el artículo de de rubiá mint es esta
transición incompleta de los ministerios
de defensa que si bien han pasado por
adecuaciones a raíz de la transición de
gobiernos militares a gobiernos civiles
en el fondo la estructuración interna de
los ministerios no ha sido no ha
evolucionado realmente y sigue habiendo
un componente militar muy fuerte lo cual
también impide la modernización de las
fuerzas armadas a nuevos desafíos a
nuevas tareas en un contexto en el cual
también el mundo está cambiando y en el
cual las fuerzas armadas
latinoamericanas pues no se han
actualizado suficientemente y el hecho
de que precisamente esa no sea la
sociedad civil la que controle esto y
quiero referirme usted lo haga
referencia al caso de méxico porque
llama la atención que efectivamente un
gobierno que aparecía con un discurso
que criticó la presencia militar ahora
haya militarizado una buena parte de las
de la sociedad mexicana y que incluso
vaya en contra de medidas que fija la
constitución de esto es bastante
sorprendente así es y sobre todo porque
va totalmente en contra del discurso de
el presidente lópez obrador cuando era
candidato a la presidencia el hecho de
cambiar la política de lucha contra el
narcotráfico que era un poco uno de sus
ejes de campaña pues se dio dio pie a
una gran continuidad en las políticas
públicas contra el crimen organizado y
que infelizmente han sido un fracaso en
méxico pero también en colombia pero
también en el resto de américa latina y
lo cual plantea el hecho que se tiene
que me parece que es también algo que
digo capítulo cambiar un poco la
estrategia de lucha contra el crimen
organizado y me parece que ya no hay que
perderle el miedo a decirlo claramente
gaspar de manera breve la corrupción
dicen ustedes aumento con la democracia
y esto genera cada vez mayor
insatisfacción durante la democracia la
corrupción aumentó es un poco fuerte
incluso por las principales víctimas que
la sociedad civil de esos países sin
duda y ahora me parece que el tema de la
corrupción hay que tomarlo con mucho
cuidado porque es difícil medir la
corrupción entonces hay una percepción
de corrupción pero es difícil poderla
estimar la con cifras con dados y datos
y poderla aterrizar yo creo que lo que
hay que hacer es efectivamente tener
programas aumentar la transparencia
y ser muy vigilantes en la ejecución del
gasto público pero la corrupción no
puede hacer el alfa y el omega de una
política pública yo creo que el
principal desafío es reducir las
desigualdades proponer este cambio de
políticas construir las mayorías
en los congresos para poder disminuir la
desigualdad disminuir la pobreza y
reconectar a las sociedades con sus
élites políticas y económicas pues
estamos llegando ya al final de esta
escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecer a gaspar a estrada que es el
director ejecutivo del observatorio
político para américa latina y el caribe
el opal del instituto de ciencias
políticas aquí en parís su presencia
para ser gaspar y enhorabuena por esta
importante revista esta importante
contribución a ustedes les damos una
próxima cita aquí la semana entrante en
otra escala en parís